let's go back to adding things to our
chart remember from the intro video that
this course was going to involve a
version control system called git you
might be wondering how git got its name
it was created in 2005 by Linus Torvalds
git is British slang for something
roughly equivalent to unpleasant person
Torvalds once said I'm an egotistical
bastard and I named all my projects
after myself first Linux now git git was
designed with code in mind it's not the
only system built with that goal though
one early widely adopted version control
system for code is called CVS concurrent
version systems another system SVN also
known as subversion is fairly similar
but improved on CVS to some extent
another system you may have heard of is
called mercurial abbreviated HG the
elemental symbol for mercury your curiel
has a lot in common with git and CVS and
SB n are pretty similar
so to avoid cluttering up our chart I'll
just add SVN and leave the others off
let's go ahead and fill in the chart for
our new entries all right so which of
these systems have the user manually
saving versus Auto saving well clearly
manual saving requires you to manually
save Wikipedia also requires this so
does SVN Dropbox and Google Docs on the
other hand save versions for you whether
or not you manually save so what does
get do it takes the manual approach
allowing the user to choose when to
create checkpoints well it may seem like
having changes saved automatically would
be convenient or nice get system makes
it much more likely that each individual
version represent a logical change we'll
expand on why this is useful later but
intuitively being able to view old
versions is much more useful if each
checkpoint is meaningful in get
terminology these user created
checkpoints are called commits commits
are the basic building blocks of get
each one representing a version of the
content at one point in time it requires
the user to supply a commit message each
time a commit is created this makes
looking through old versions much more
useful and pleasant than the Google Docs
model assuming that the user supplied a
useful commit message you'll actually
get a chance to see what this looks like
and get soon with Caroline